dark souls 1 is a fantastic game it's got a
wonderful story that would set in motion numerous
events that would occur throughout the trilogy
but just within the bounds of its own game
dark souls 1 has some incredibly deep and
rich lore filled with some of the greatest
backstories this series has to offer and today
i want to discuss why, so without further ado
let's get started so the opening cinematic of
dark souls 1 starts at the gray world one that is
filled with giant trees and dragons and while the
world stayed like that for a while one day fire
was born as for how this fire came to be well it's
never explained this is one of the many things we
just have to accept the world of dark souls is
fantasy and many things just can't be explained
it's never mentioned how the first flame was
created as it just happened but because the
first flame was born disparity came with it life
and death heat and cold and light and dark this
description is literal since the first flame was
created the people of the world felt its warmth
and understood what heat was when they walked
away from the flame they realized its heat didn't
reach them which created the feeling of cold the
discovery of fire during the stone age is to this
day the greatest discovery known to man and in
dark souls this is no different given how unique
something like this in the world of dark souls was
those who discovered it were obviously attracted
to its power four notable people would discover
lord souls next to these flames and be given
immense power these people were nito izalith gwyn
and the pygmy from the intro we can infer that
there was a civilization of people that existed
during the age of ancients izalith had daughters
that were with her when she found her lord's
soul and gwyn had his nights with him implying
that people did exist during the time of the age
of ancients but weren't of much value to the world
given how powerful the dragons were eventually
nito izalith and gwyn would band together and
use their power to overthrow the dragons gwyn used
this lightning izalith used her flames and nito
used his death and disease they also received help
from a seath the scalists a dragon who betrayed
his own kind now that the new lords were on top of
the food chain the age of ancients was no more and
the age of fire had begun this period would last
thousands of years until we get to today currently
the fire is fading and it needs to be rekindled
in order to keep it lit but doing this is not
as simple as it sounds you may have noticed i
forgot to talk about the pygmy well the pygmy
had a unique soul called the dark soul using his
soul he created something called humanity he would
then share this humanity with his people these
dark soul imbued people became known as humans
the pygmy is essentially our ancestor gwyn feared
this power though and created the dark sign which
inadvertently caused the undead curse this isn't
explained much in dark souls 1 but it is by far
the most important plot in the whole series and
while i just wanted to talk about this game for
the whole video this needs to be explained or
else the rest of the video going forward will
make no sense the undead curse the dark sign
and the fading of the fire are all linked the
dark soul gets more powerful the closer the fire
is to fading thus meaning humans should get more
powerful over time but gwyn screwed humanity twice
by rekindling the flame thus removing our chance
at power but also by branding humans with the dark
side think of this as a literal wall of fire that
prevents the dark soul within men from getting
too powerful the dark side only activates when
the flame is fading because that is when the dark
soul within men starts to grow stronger this dark
sign also prevents humans from dying but it also
causes them to go undead these fleshy creatures
were once undead humans but they have crossed the
barrier of no return even though humans are able
to revive after death eventually this will cause
them to lose their humanity lose their minds and
lose their purpose causing them to go hollow
these creatures are hollows beings who don't
even remember who they are where they are or what
they're even doing gwyn likes being on top and he
fears the day that he will lose his power so he'll
do anything he can to prevent that from happening
he did this by branding humanity with the
dark side but by also rekindling the flame
which is known as the first sin see the world
is like a set of operations things are born but
eventually they'll die but then more things
will be born only to die soon after that's
just the way the world works but gwyn broke the
laws of the world by rekindling the first flame
it was meant to be extinguished but due to
gwyn wanting to hold on to what he held dear
he couldn't dare see it go he sacrificed himself
by using himself as kindling for the first flame
since he had one of the four original lord
souls that came from the first flame it was
deemed sufficient enough to be used as fuel unless
the gauge of fire continued but as we know it is
fading once more the undead curse is back humans
are turning hollow and the world is in chaos
doesn't this sound like a fantastic story that's
because it is this intro and even the game display
a sense of desperation within our characters
how far people willing to go to get what they
want or keep what they have and while each of
their desires is different it always comes out
the same dark souls 1 is just the start but the
actions of its characters will continue to echo
throughout the entire trilogy and we're just
getting started after the opening cinematic
we get to see the state of the world as it is
today or at least the state of this prison we're
an undead that is sitting in their cell awaiting
the end of the world but one day we're given the
key to our cell and are able to leave this person
is oscar and he speaks of a prophecy there is an
old saying in my family thou who art undead are
chosen and thine exodus from the undead asylum
maketh pilgrimage to the land of ancient
lords when thou ringeth the bell of awakening
the fate of the undead thou shalt know this
prophecy also happens to be the main objective
of the game but it's only the first part the
rest we'll have to discover later the intro of
dark souls 1 sets up a new world by showcasing
multiple important events in the world's history
and also gives us enough information to understand
the basic premise of the game while also purposely
withholding some of that information to give us
a reason to seek out said information one thing
we need to consider though is our character's
motivations why even bother making the trip
to lordran the land of lords well what else is
there to do it's the end of the world and you
were just given the keys to your cell allowing
you to explore the world to your heart's content
even if you're convinced that life is doomed in
the world as we know it will disappear for good
why not make the most out of it have some fun kill
some hollows it's a whole lot better than rotting
in a cell with our objective laid out to us thanks
to oscar we can now set out to lordran and ring
the bells technically the first area you're meant
to go is the undead burg but one wrong step and
you can make it to new londo out of all the souls
games dark souls 1 will provide the best blind
playthrough as due to its connected world players
will go in different directions which in turn will
create different experiences new londo is actually
a late game area since the enemies here are quite
strong and the boss at the end of the level is
quite tough but you may stumble upon this area
by accident within five minutes of arriving
this is due in part to dark souls ones a level
design which may have the best level design in the
whole franchise it's been coined as a metroidvania
a genre that started with the game's metroid
and castlevania these games have non-linear
progression as many areas can be accessed right
away but others can't causing the player to go
around the map looking for the key then running
back to that same location such as this door that
leads to havel which can only be found in the dark
route basin past the boss the door is found pretty
early on in your playthrough but the key is found
much later plus you'll also have to remember where
that key goes you'll be doing lots of running
in this game the highlight of one of my play
sessions was going from blighttown to andre
because i forgot to ascend my weapon before
a boss fight meaning i had to take a three minute
walk up to him then a three minute walk back down
in future titles this would be remedied by fast
travel but dark souls 1 doesn't have fast travel
initially and even when you do gain the power
of fast travel via the lord vessel it's not
the typical fast travel we're familiar with as
we're only allowed to travel to specific bonfires
these decisions further immerse the player
into the world as it's all one connected level
and since they're all connected that means you
can see certain levels from different places
such as blighttown which is visible from firelink
shrine so not only was the level design of each
area taken into account but also how the levels
connected to one another and how this connection
would affect other areas regardless of where you
end up though whether that be new londo or undead
burg the very first enemies you'll come to see are
these hollow men like the ones back in the asylum
all the undead we see here are humans who have
lost their humanity causing them to go hollow
and now since we are human we should go hollow too
however it's a bit more meta than that hollowing
is a bit hard to define as everyone can go hollow
for different reasons but the two main ideas seem
to stem from constant death or a loss of purpose
given that our character is set on ringing the
bells he never goes hollow despite being undead as
he still has a purpose should the player quit and
uninstall the game they would lose their purpose
so permanently quitting the game is sort of like
hollowing in a sense i don't think everything
needs to be explained with lore so this is more
than likely just a gameplay mechanic but that's
how i've interpreted hollowing on our way to
the bells of awakening will come across various
different locations but sadly there isn't a whole
lot of backstory involved in their creation
locations like undead burg are just undead
settlements and the valley of drake's is just
a valley filled with drakes the only exceptions
though are ash lake and blighttown blighttown is
next to a location called the depths and at the
end of the depths is the gaping dragon and while
an interesting boss what's more important is the
arena we can see water coming from the depths
and going into the sewer system which leads to
blighttown according to various keys in the game
we can piece together that those who previously
lived in the undead burg but were banished
from the settlement were sent to blighttown
as punishment this is reinforced by the giant door
that separates the sewer system from the outside
world but this water from the sewer is poisonous
well in blighttown there's a spell called poison
mist and according to its description it seems
that eingyi this egg-bearing individual may have
caused this as he was the creator of the poison
miss spell it's not fully confirmed that he did
this but it's clear that blighttown isn't in the
greatest state and it's due to the circumstances
surrounding blighttown that the townsfolk seem
to have built above the water in hopes of getting
away from it this is a common theme in these games
of things being built on top of one another as we
see blighttown above the swamp depths above
blighttown and the undead burg above all that
the idea of pushing things down and leaving them
to fester is also a common theme within this game
but not everything is in such a sad state as
at the lowest point of lordran we see ash lake
a seemingly infinite land filled with archeries
that are surrounded by an equally infinite body
this seems to be where the dragons used to live or
at least one part of it as it's eerily similar to
the environment in the intro which we do know was
the land of the everlasting dragons we can even
find one of the few remaining dragons down here
in ash lake he's a part of the dragon covenant
in-game and from various descriptions it seems
like many people worship the dragons and tried
to ascend to their level it's unclear though if
that worked once the player feels confident in
their fighting abilities they can approach the
bosses defending the bells of awakening these
being the bell gargoyles and chaos witch quelaag
after bringing both bells we'll see that sen's
fortress a place that was originally blocked with
a large gate is now open but if we travel back to
firelink shrine we'll find a primordial serpent
named frampt he claims to be a close friend of
gwyns and also claims to know our fate very
well then i am pleased to share chosen undead
your fate is to succeed the great lord
gwyn so that you may link the fire
cast away the dark and undo the curse of the
undead to this end you must visit anor londo
and acquire the lord vessel just like before
this second part of the prophecy also happens
to be our newest objective but frampt is quite a
complex character if certain conditions are met
within the game we can also be granted an audience
with kaathe he however tells us a different story
your ancestor claimed the dark soul and waited
for fire to subside and soon the flames did fade
and only dark remained thus began the age of men
the age of dark so it wasn't just the fact that
the fire was fading that caused gwen to rekindle
it the flame actually went out furthermore despite
being the same species both frampt and kaathe have
different views on the world frampt wants to keep
the age of fire going but kaathe wants to usher
in an age of darkness the question is who do
we trust well that's up to you as these are the
two endings of the game extinguish the flame or
rekindle it the choice is yours what is important
to note though is their motivations why are they
doing this why are they against each other well
we still don't know and it's been a widely debated
topic that hasn't been given a proper answer yet
regardless i don't think you should trust any of
them frampt claims that the undead curse will be
cured if we link the flame but this isn't correct
as we'll see in dark souls 2 and 3 the curse
is still present frampt and kaathe are like
politicians, they say what needs to be said but
never elaborate by technicality the undead curse
will be cured when we link the flame as we know
the darksign only appears when fire fades and if
it's not fading then the curse of the dark sign
is gone which means the curse goes with it but
it will eventually come back things are meant to
run their course so over time the fire will fade
again and the curse will come back just not in our
character's lifetime frampt whether intentional or
not is leading the player to believe that the
curse will disappear permanently when indeed it
only just disappears for a few thousand years but
kaathe is also lying as he isn't fully explaining
what this age of darkness entails and as we'll see
kaathe isn't exactly the nicest person in the soul's
universe i've always seen these two as immortal
beings ones that are ageless and due to this when
the time comes they like to move the pieces a bit
and see what happens kaathe and frampt are basically
playing a long game of chess but without the
stakes regardless of who wins they both continue
to live one just managed to convince the chosen
undead more so why not cause a bit of chaos a lie
or two here wouldn't hurt anybody as it's just
extra pieces on the board to them to this day
we still don't know what they really want from us
and whether their goals they conveyed to us were
actually genuine my interpretation of these could
be wildly incorrect but that's the beauty of these
games they allow you to shape your own story
and create your own adventure and in my story
i don't trust these two regardless of who you
believe the one thing they agree on is that we
need the lord vessel thus we need to get to anor
londo to get there we'll need to pass through
sen's fortress a place filled with deadly traps
and is easily the most infuriating area in the
whole game the fortress is also used as a sort
of trial as this leads us to anor londo but many
people have tried and failed to get there this is
of course due to the numerous traps throughout the
fortress and the iron golem at the top although he
was surprisingly the easiest part of the fortress
once the golem is defeated we are then grabbed
by these demons and taken to anor londo
it's hard to forget your first time in anor
londo nothing up until this point has been more
extravagant and beautiful looking than this place
and that's what makes it so memorable in a world
devoid of beauty and color there's this incredible
place that just exists but it's on the other side
of the wall but something is off it feels empty
like we showed up late to a party and in a more
metaphorical and literal sense we have this
place is gorgeous but if you'll excuse the pun
it's also quite hollow lots of your time in
anor londo is spent walking but if you manage
to make it past these giants and exploit the
ai of these silver knights then you'll make it
to the climactic fight of ornstein and smough, O&S is
undoubtedly my favorite fight in dark souls 1 the
balance of these two is unmatched as ornstein
is a quick nimble fighter that can go halfway
across the arena just to hit you but his damage
is nowhere near as staggering as the force that
is smough whereas ornstein instills fear from his
speed smoughs fear comes from his power ornstein
at the beginning of the fight is more or less a
pushover he does deal decent damage but it's not
enough to warrant a healing item but no amount of
damage resistance especially this early on could
protect you from smough's hammer and one hit from
this hammer can make orenstein seem a lot more
threatening their power grows from the other's
presence as the more ornstein chips at your health
the closer you are to being within one shot range
of smough and if smough hits you once well there's
nothing that can compare to that level of stress
they feed off each other in such a balanced way in
fact they actually feed on each other as whoever
falls first becomes the power source for the other
their health also goes back to full so it's
never about dwindling them down over time it's
committing to one and sticking with it the problem
is knowing when to strike and how given how well
they complement each other it might seem like
there's never an opening and that's what makes
them such a difficult fight all that's required
though from the player is patience it's arguably
one of the best fights in the game and even
the series as a whole and i can finally see why
while O&S may seem like the climactic finish
to the level hold your load as behind them is
the real climax the princess of sunlight Gwynevere
feel free to interpret climax however you want she
is the one who gives us the lord vessel we need
to progress through the game but as i said earlier
it feels like we arrived late to a party well i
wasn't lying once the post nut clarity settles
in if we attack gwynevere the world of anor londo
shows its true colors and reveals that it's just
as depressing as everything else in lordran and
the one responsible for this illusion is dark
sun gwyndolin, gwyndolin is an interesting case to
me as he was the last born child of gwyn who was
a male but was raised as a female this was due to
his strong affinity with moon magic i'm not sure
what the connection is but maybe it's some sort of
cultural thing where the moon is seen as a sort of
feminine symbol which would actually explain a lot
regarding a future game and two of its characters
gwyndolin also created the illusion of anor londo
to seemingly entice the chosen undead to continue
their duty remember gwyndolin only appears when
we kill gwynevere illusion meaning that this
is actually gwyndolin speaking to us through
his sister he also shares the same viewpoints
as frampt which is interesting as he's basically
telling us to kill his father and continue the
age of fire gwyndolin seems to want to hold on to
the power his family has and keep things running
smoothly which is why he wants the age of fire to
continue so that his family and their powers can
stay and the reason why he created the illusion of
anor londo was also to desperately hold on to the
past ha i guess it runs in the family then as for
how gwynevere fits into this while she was gwyn's
second born child who like many other deities
left in orlando she would then meet with a flame
god flan and later become his wife besides these
two gwyn had two other children but we'll have to
wait for dark souls 3 to discuss more about them
so in orlando the city of gods this place that
was supposed to be seen as a beacon of hope to all
within lordran is just an illusion but anor londo
isn't the only illusion of lordran but making our
way to the painting inside the city upon touching
it were thrown into the painted world of ariamis
ariamis as a concept is fascinating as it's this
world within a world and these people inside the
painting could possibly never know of the world
outside of it from exploring this hidden world
we learn that ariamis was made for things the
gods feared ariamis is home to the followers of
velka and velka is known as the goddess of sin
furthermore this is the only location in the game
where you can find the dark ember which according
to its item description is used to make occult
weaponry weapons that were favorable amongst those
who plan to kill the gods and their kin velka was
more than likely someone who wanted to hunt the
gods but was killed or thrown into the painting
it's clear that this place has a malicious history
behind it but it's not all bad as the person
who watches over ariamis is crossbreed priscilla
priscilla is a half-human half-dragon crossbreed
due to this unique birth she also gained some
unique abilities mainly the ability of life hunt
which he uses on her scythe these powers of hers
could threaten the gods rule so they also threw
her into the painted world but what's rather
interesting is priscilla herself she's the only
boss in the game that doesn't want to fight us
she even tells us how to leave ariamus meaning not
only does she have no intent of enacting revenge
but she knows how to leave yet refuses priscilla
may have felt how these new arrivals feel but
instead of using vengeance she uses acceptance
and instead welcomes these people into her painted
world it's actually quite wholesome and is the
reason why i couldn't kill her every boss in
this game is hell-bent on killing me so when i
finally discovered one that didn't want to and
in fact help me i couldn't refuse so i left with
the hope that priscilla would be able to make this
place a proper home for her people this whole area
is swarming with hollows and other creatures that
want nothing more than to kill us but they were
either tricked into here or thrown in because the
gods willed it and yeah some of them probably
do belong in here but if priscilla is set on
making this place a home for those who have found
themselves here then who am i to intervene after
acquiring the lord vessel when we meet with koth
or frampt they'll tell us that to gain access to
gwyn we must gather the remaining lord souls and
use them to satiate the lord vessel these lord
souls belong to four individuals seath the scaleless
the witch of izalith nito and the four kings three
of whom you will have already recognized from
here we can tackle the game in any order we want
so let's start with the four kings the four kings
are well four kings who ruled over new londo they
were given fragments of gwyn's soul which is why
we need to kill them you may recognize their boss
location as this is the same dark abyss that
we met kaathe well long ago the four kings
were tricked by kaathe and were consumed by the
abyss this caused the kings to go mad and this
also caused the citizens to either become these
blobs of mass or the dark wraith soldiers this
area really utilizes the environment to tell its
tale as this place is overrun by the ghosts of the
villagers and when we actually unlock the door to
lower new londo we see piles of corpses scattered
throughout the land kaathe single-handedly destroyed
an entire city simply by tricking its inhabitants
and unleashing the abyss upon them while the
mass extinction of a city sounds bad there is
still more destruction to be seen one thing you
may have noticed is a severe lack of human bosses
quelaag would probably count as the first one
you'd meet although she's sort of half human but
there's a reason for this as this has to do with
the witch of izalith while gwyn was frantically
running around trying to figure out what to do
with the flame the witch of izalith had a plan she
was going to create a new flame that would replace
the first flame but she attempted to create a
replica in the presence of the very thing that was
created which brought with it massive consequences
the witch of izalith wanted to create a new first
flame but there was already a first flame present
in the world there can't be two first flames due
to this the flame that she created couldn't be
contained for long causing it to erupt and this
not only consumed her and her children but also
created new life as it gave birth to demons the
asylum taurus and capra demon roughly the first
three bosses in the game were created from this
event in fact anything that has the word demon
in it is most likely derived from this flame of
chaos but not only was new life created old life
was altered all of izalith's family who were caught
in the explosion were all transformed into demons
themselves chaos which quelaag the fair lady
and ceaseless discharge are three of izalith's
children just as gwyn was desperate to continue
the age of fire in an attempt to keep what he
had so too did izalith but the consequences are
a reflection of her actions in an attempt to give
life to something bright and warm she ended up
giving life to something cold and dark she also
wanted to extend the age of fire in order to
continue her prosperous life with her children
but by doing so she ended up making their lives
a living hell not a single person in this family
tree is living a robust life anymore quelaag and
her sister the fair lady are half demon and are
more than likely suffering from their condition
as told to us by the fair lady
ceaseless discharge was covered in lava sores
from birth so his life was a living hell from
the start the flame of chaos just made it worse
ceaseless discharge just like priscilla doesn't
actually want to fight us it's only until we
steal this clothing set that he attacks us this
clothing set rests upon a grave that belonged to
his sister quelana who he believes died in the
explosion when in fact she was the only one who
escaped quelana will appear in blighttown if
the player is sufficient enough in pyromancy
quelana explains that she was the only one who
made it out of the reaches of the flame of chaos
in fact she was actually able to harness the power
of the flame of chaos and create magic which we
know as pyromancy quelana wants us to fulfill her
duty for her as she does not have the strength to
go on she instructs us that we need to put down
her siblings and her mother so that they may rest
in peace this whole family dynamic is horrific as
ceaseless believes that all his sisters are dead
even though qulana is alive and quelana is only
a few meters from her sister and yet we can tell
her about this clearly this is turning into a very
depressing story but it only gets worse as we get
closer to the final boss of the area we'll meet
with a pyromancer who is assumed to be another
daughter of izalith although it's unclear why she
is so far down in these ruins yet is completely
unharmed it's possible that she like quelana
escaped the flame of chaos but this daughter
came back to finish off the boss right behind her
or has possibly gone insane and is now defending
said boss and by going down this slide we will
meet this monstrosity who is the bed of chaos
this is the witch of izalith one of the four most
powerful people in the world has been demoted to
this deformed tree-like creature there are also
these orbs next to her that we need to destroy
in order to damage her and it's assumed by many
that these are her other two daughters that were
closest to her when the flame erupted so we have
two daughters stuck to their mother two daughters
who were half afflicted by the flame a son who
is arguably the most affected and two daughters
who manage to survive one who doesn't have the
strength to carry on anymore and another who sits
outside her mother's arena this is by far the most
depressing story i've ever had the misfortune of
uncovering the further we push into lost izalith
the more of the family we get to meet allowing
us to see the consequences of her actions we can
see the pain that all of them are in as some of
them are just wishing for their siblings back and
others just want to stay alive it's an awful story
that all leads to the final fight with izalith
herself and it is by far the most anti-climactic
ending i've ever experienced it is agreed upon by
many that the bet of chaos is the worst fight in
dark souls 1. the boss is insanely difficult but
it's not the difficulty itself that's the issue
it's why the boss is difficult i would argue that
just within the main game the two hardest bosses
are the four kings and ornstein and smough
are difficult bosses because there's two of them
you have to have both on screen at all times or
you'll lose this fight this is balanced by having
ornstein be fast but not as lethal and smough being
slow and hard-hitting it's a wonderful dichotomy
that makes for a satisfying fight and the four
kings is a dps check as every 30 to 45 seconds
a second king will spawn and this will keep going
until 4 on your screen at once to succeed you need
to kill the current king before this happens both
boss fights are hard but have weaknesses you can
exploit the bet of chaos has none to defeat the
boss you need to destroy both orbs on her sides
then go down the middle inside of her so you
can find the source of her power she's actually
extremely weak as both the orbs and her die in one
hit it's getting there that's the issue her hand
attack is oddly timed and due to her design it's
unclear where her hitbox ends after defeating one
of the orbs the floor will start to crumble so not
only do you need to avoid her attacks but you'll
also need to avoid the floor there's also a strict
path you're meant to follow for this fight which
will lead you right next to a broken piece and
the flooring so you'll more than likely get hit
and fall in and die the walk back to this boss is
also just as atrocious as you'll more than likely
spend more time walking to the boss than actually
fighting her thankfully there is no reset involved
in this boss as every single run you've done is
carried over to the next as it essentially has
unlimited checkpoints it's like from software knew
it was bad but still kept it in even if i actually
enjoyed the fight the payoff narratively isn't
worth the time we ventured further and further
into the depths of lost izalith coming across all
of her children who were these hideous beasts that
did incredible damage and she's just a puzzle the
witch of izalith has one of the best backstories
in the game as the tale of her children is
heartbreaking and being able to see their
conditions face to face does take a lot out of you
but it's completely soured by a boss fight that is
mechanically and narratively a letdown our third
lord soul belongs to grave lord nito and he's
interesting to say the least nito might have the
most detailed boss design but the most basic story
out of all the four lords if you were to just
assume that nito simply became the grim reaper
and just administered death you wouldn't be
far off which is a shame for someone of his
importance gravelord nito lives in the tomb
of giants which is accessed via the catacombs
both these areas share a similar theme of death as
this is where the dead are buried so we know that
he administers death but what else does he do well
not much else he does have a covenant that you can
join but their goal is just to spread more death
across the world it seems like he doesn't care
about what's going on in the world as the only
reason he attacks you is because we're obviously
here with malicious intent leader doesn't have any
lore regarding his life during the age of fire and
it's just about him administering death from this
we can infer that nito either doesn't care about
the age of fire or maybe even just wants the age
of darkness to occur the only other bit of lore
surrounding him is a boss named pinwheel who is a
necromancer presumably made up of three people as
referenced by the number of masks on the
body who stole an item from him known as the
rite of kindling there are quite a few theories
regarding pinwheel like the fact that pinwheel was
originally a father but his wife and child died so
he attempted to resurrect them but it failed and
some have stated further that he's still trying
to figure out how to revive them as we can see
skeletons throughout the room which could be seen
as his test subjects but other than that we've
pretty much discussed all of nito there
isn't anything else to speak about which is a
real shame his backstory has a massive amount of
potential but it just felt unfinished there are no
major themes tied to nito he just kinda exists our
final lord soul belongs to seath the scaleless seath as
we remember allied himself with our four lords
and attacked the dragons the reason he did this
was because seath unlike the other dragons was not
immortal all the other dragons had impenetrable
scales that could not be broken with any type
of weapon sheath was not born with these scales
so in a sense he was not immortal it was only
until gwyn was given their weakness from seath
which we know is lightning that gwyn was able to
pierce the dragon's scales and actually kill them
seath was envious of his brethren as they had what
he didn't so as thanks for working with gwyn he
was named the duke and given the duke's archives
as well as some of gwyn's lord soul for power
during the war seath found the primordial crystal
an item that gave him temporary immortality but
during this time in the duke's archives he
eventually went mad with his experiments in
his research he is considered the grandfather of
sorcery as well as the creator of these creatures
and the moonlight butterfly our first interaction
with seath is that he ends up killing us
and throwing us in a prison cell we can see that
theme of desperation as seth is trying everything
he can to get what he wants but in the process it
made him mad he's not as mindful of his actions as
he used to be in a sort of a shadow of his former
self one thing i find interesting in this prison
is the abundance of miracle-related items and the
clothing that are scattered throughout the prison
it's possible that clerics were deemed suitable
subjects for seath experiments maybe this is due
to their magical power or because they were so
easy to defeat to kill seath though we need to
head to the crystal caves which i was originally
going to say was probably the worst level in this
game due to half the map being invisible but the
walk to the boss is surprisingly straightforward
venturing off that path though is where the
problem lies to defeat seath we need to break
his primordial crystal so that we can sever his
immortality giving us a chance to kill him the
story of these lords caused a bit of an imbalance
throughout my playthrough you can go through lost
izalith and the demon ruins which is filled with
rich lore tons of backstory and compelling bosses
that fit with the lore surrounding the witch of
izalith but then you go to the four kings and just
find out that they were lords of new londo who
got tricked by kaathe and consumed by the abyss it
feels jarring going from one to the other as one
feels thorough while the other feels incomplete
like you missed something or there was more that
should have been said i don't think every boss
needs to have a multi-page wikipedia article in
order for it to be considered a good story i think
that the boss's story said what needed to be said
in regards to the overarching plot but i can't
lie to you and tell you that i didn't leave these
locations wanting more i wanted to know more about
the four kings and how they rose to power and i
wanted to know more about nito and sith in general
but i never got that and i guess in a way this
could be viewed as a positive as i didn't walk out
of these places not wanting to learn them at all
but rather wanted to learn more the game invested
me so much into its story thanks to its characters
and environmental storytelling that i wanted the
game to provide me with more information on it
i wanted to be encapsulated by this story more
than i already was as with many souls games not
all answers are explicitly told to us but there
were still a lot of burning questions i had that
never got mentioned with the lord's souls on the
vessel we are now able to fight gwyn but we still
have one final location we need to visit which is
the land of oolacile accessed by the artorius of
the abyss dlc the one and only dlc that dark souls
1 would have we start this dlc by defeating this
gold golem that has a woman named dusk captured
inside dusk was the princess of a place called
oolacile according to her it's a place from an
age that existed long ago hilariously enough she
doesn't actually say anything after this you would
think that the dlc would sort of spin a story that
her home is in danger and we need to save her but
she doesn't actually tell us that she just sells
us sorceries the dlc doesn't officially start
though until we return back to her location with
an item called the broken pendant which causes us
to get sucked in into this portal and taken to
oolacile as dusk said oolacile was a place from
long ago and while you may be confused on how this
fits within the geography of lordran this place is
a lot closer than you think in fact we already ran
through it to get to the dlc the dark rouge garden
is oolacile this is evident by the tree enemies
who have a similar design to these tree-like
enemies and the same plants that are only found in
the dark root garden are also found here as well
oolusio was a city hundreds of years before the
dark rouge garden came to be so something happened
that made this place turn into the garden that we
know of well to understand the story of oolacile we
need to talk to elizabeth but princess dusk is
here no longer snatched away by that horrifying
primeval human and so i must ask could thou
once more play the savior an abyss was begat
of the ancient beast and threatens to swallow the
whole of oolacile knight artorias came to stop this
but such a hero has neary a murmur of dark
without doubt he will be swallowed by the abyss
overcome by its utter blackness indeed the
abyss may be unstoppable still i have faith that
princess dusk may be rescued yet this prime evil
human is manus of the abyss the final boss of the
dlc and the thing that sucked us into oolacile in
the first place so our job is to hunt manus down
my main gripe with the dlc is justification as
technically with the lord vessel we can just leave
so why do we need to worry about this it's not an
immersion breaking problem but it is a shame while
traveling through the land of oolacile you will
come across this coliseum-like structure which is
where we get to meet our next boss artorias of the
abyss artorias was one of the four knights of gwyn
the other three are hawkeye gough who is sitting
at the top of the tower right next to the coliseum
ciaran who appears in the coliseum after we defeat
artorias and the final light is ornstein each of
them were skilled in their own ways as hawkeye
used his powerful grepo to shoot down dragons in
fact he can actually help us shoot down calamite
who was the last of the ancient dragons ornstein
also used his spear that was able to cut through
the scales of dragons with ease and we can also
see the spoils of his war due to the amount of
dragon heads that exist in anor londo artorius is
also able to wield his greatsword with incredible
finesse and ciaran used her two daggers to cut down
anyone who opposed gwyn's rule but all of them
minus ornstein are way past their prime which
is a growing theme amongst the entire series gough
was imprisoned in this tower with nothing left to
do but to make carvings he also couldn't use his
great bow anymore as all the dragons have been
wiped out so he has no purpose ciaran may have had
a deep love for artorias says when we visit her she
is next to the grave she made for him and asks
if we can give her his soul if we do she gives
us her weapons and continues to sit by the grave
implying that she no longer wants to be a knight
anymore and artorias came to oolacile in an attempt to
stop the abyss from spreading but ended up losing
and being corrupted himself his left arm is also
dangling which might suggest that it's broken this
is because he used his shield to protect his
wolf companion sif the same sif from the main
game although he is much smaller in this dlc sif
also has a different intro if you do the dlc first
because oolacile is in the past so he'll remember
you in the present and it makes killing him that
much harder in regards to sif it's possible that
he doesn't want us getting the covenant of the
abyss ring as that allows us to travel through
the abyss to kill the four kings and given his
owner's condition sif probably doesn't want us
to end up like artorias the artorias boss fight
was actually really entertaining he was the first
boss that felt like the antithesis of this game's
combat most of the game's pace has been very slow
and methodical but he has these fast attacks and
very few openers i do wish though that there was
at least an ounce of build up to this fight as
you can literally start the dlc and be at the boss
room in about 10 minutes i think having the player
traverse some of the areas that are covered in
these abyss creatures that grow in number as we
get closer to artorias would have been great
as it's slowly leading us towards this person
responsible for all this death well narratively it
felt a bit too fast for me the fight mechanically
was great after artorias we can explore the rest
of oolacile and we can see how much this land has
been affected by the abyss as all the inhabitants
have been infected by this dark energy turning
them into these disgusting creatures eventually
we'll reach the bottom and this feeling of fear
starts to set in as the world becomes darker and
darker the further we go down here in the chasm of
the abyss is where the darkness reaches its peak
and it's where these dark sprites of humanity live
these are very similar in design to the actual
humanity we consume in game this seems to be
humanity in a more physical form one that is
more exposed and not constricted by the dark side
at the foot of the chasm is our final boss
manus the father of the abyss manus has an
interesting story apparently the people of oolacile
were tricked by a serpent who was probably coughed
into digging manus grave up in doing so it caused
manus to go wild and unleash his wrath upon them
according to his soul manus was once a human
but became father of the abyss when his humanity
went wild and now he eternally seeks his broken
pendant the same pendant we had to find to start
the dlc it's unclear why he liked this pendant so
much but it was possibly nostalgic to him or was
given to him by someone he loved and because this
pendant was so important to him he did everything
he could to get it back which inevitably drove him
to insanity it seems that he got so desperate to
find the pendant that he pulled in random people
into this world as the npc marvelous chester is
clearly not from this world and he even says so
himself he also kind of looks like the hunters
from bloodborne which is a nice reference to the
game the main question many within the community
have though is who was manus before he became his
current deformed state well we really don't know
many have said it's the furtive pygmy and i like
that idea but i think it's less interesting than
that many of the spells in this dlc say that
they were created by an oolacilian sorcerer on
the brink of madness i can't help but think that
this is perfect for manus's description one thing
that is interesting is that in the middle of the
arena is a grave with a humanity-shaped hole so
maybe manus was one of these humanity sprites when
he died or that this is what he turned into when
he died regardless it's a very interesting detail
i also couldn't get any footage of this as she
disappears when you leave the boss room but dusk
apparently appears out of manus when we kill him
meaning that he kidnapped her this may confuse
some people as dusk has been sort of all over
the place in this game and due to her going from
the past to the present it sort of screws with the
time a bit it seems like she was sent into our
time somehow and was captured by this golem she
then disappears and goes back into her time which
then leads to the abyss incident with the people
of oolacile artorias is then called to defeat the
abyss but fails and then we get summoned into this
world via manus hand then save dusk and go back to
the present it's still a little confusing and the
world of dark souls is also very confusing when it
comes to time as always during this fading of the
fire time is very convoluted because we can summon
people as phantoms and the time sort of stops
it's very confusing but that's how i think it
went down but with manus dead we have officially
finished the dlc however this won't be the last
time we'll hear of manus but that's for dark souls2
artorias of the abyss was a great dlc while it
does lack in motivation in regards to the player
the actual story of the dlc was great it provides
us with a nice timeline of events as well as more
insight into the abyss and its effects on the
world and while not known at the time it would
eventually set up the plot to dark souls 2. it is
without a doubt a worthy extension to the game's
story but now we can finally go to the kiln of
the first flame and determine the fate of lordran
the kiln is coated in action we can see the
spirits of those who followed gwyn into the
kiln walk around aimlessly as we approach the
first flame we have one person in our way and
that is the lord of sunlight himself earlier i
said gwyn sacrificed himself to rekindle the flame
and he did but because of his lord soul's power
he was able to keep his body but his mind was gone
gwyn has gone hollow and while i'm
more than capable of killing him myself
i couldn't dare start the fight without the guy
who's been by my side since the very beginning
solaire of astora is easily the most well-known
npc in the entire souls franchise and his story is
a perfect representation of the mood this game is
trying to convey throughout the whole game we've
been meeting with npcs of all kinds some with
goals and others without but none of them have
managed to touch my heart in a way that solaire
and siegmeyer did both of them had a goal in mind
one wants to find his sunlight and the other
wants to explore the world but both are stuck
sigmar always seems to be getting himself caught
in some situation whether that be a locked gate
he can enter or a poison swap he can cross and
solaire can find his sunlight they both willingly
became undead in order to achieve their goals and
it tore me apart to hear that sigmar couldn't see
it through sigmar prides himself on being a knight
of catarina and that he can handle all of his
troubles on his own but with my help i showed
him that he wasn't a worthy knight after all
and that he always needed someone to rescue him
more often than not in these games your assistance
will lead to their death so it's either converse
with them and enjoy their company knowing that
they will die because of you or distance yourself
from them knowing that while it hurts it's better
that they get to live another day npcs of these
games will usually end up achieving a terrible
fate but this sadness makes the few times a happy
outcome occurs all the better solaire wasn't able
to find sunlight of his own he became depressed
and wondered if this journey was really worth
taking conveying the tone of the entire game is
our journey and our struggle really worth it in
the end which is why i owed it to him to make it
right it may not be the actual sun but the first
flame could be considered the sun so for one final
time i summoned solaire and we took down lord gwyn
gwyn's theme has such a fitting tune all these
bosses have these intense sounds with loud music
but gwyn's is such a simple piano it's not intense
it's almost sad in a way that the most powerful
man in the world has been reduced to nothing
and what was supposed to be a glorious fight
between two warriors really isn't it makes it
all the more worse when you realize that gwyn
can be parried and once you nail this timing down
this fight is a cake walk further showing how far
from grace he has truly fallen with gwyn defeated
we can now choose our ending but we aren't the
only one who's able to choose since we managed to
bring solaire all the way to the end of the game
he was able to also fight gwyn in his own world
thanks to the convoluted timelines of dark souls
and it is canonized that he succeeded and linked
the flame in his own world he became the sunlight
he was searching for and that might be one of
the greatest endings in the entire franchise
but while solaire linked the flame that doesn't
mean we have to if we choose the age of fire
the world continues we rekindle the flame and use
ourselves as kindling to continue this age of fire
if we instead choose to leave we let the flame
extinguish itself we join the primordial serpents
including kaathe and probably frampt and usher
in an age of dark one where humanity is at
the top and we ourselves are the ruler at least
that's what we think will happen like many plots
in the souls series this is once again left up
to interpretation we only get to see the very
beginning of our choice so anything after is just
pure speculation who knows what will happen after
and who knows if our choice was really the
correct one that's always been up to the
player to decide but i've always felt that these
endings are about comfort do we stay comfortable
knowing that in the age of fire we aren't on
top and might be mistreated due to our lack of
strength or do we take the risk and see what the
age of dark is about one thing to note though is
the circumstances regarding these endings fram
says that the undead curse will be cured if we
go with the age of fire and not even kaathe says
anything about this when we talk with him about
it so does that mean that we'll stay undead or
at least still have the risk of going hollow
in the age of dark furthermore the age of fire
was a time ruled by the gods and they did what
they could to keep it that way but we killed
them everyone in anor londo that is a god is
either dead or gone gwyndolin is the only one
that canonically lives thanks to dark souls 3.
so even though an age of fire can be seen as the
age of gods that might not be true anymore as we
took care of most of them so there is positives
and negatives both ways and that's really been
the point there's never going to be a clear
answer it's just whatever you think is right as
for me i think an age of dark is the proper way
to go as we said in the intro the world of dark
souls is like a set of operations things come
and things go and the age of dark should have
followed after the age of fire but due to gwen
breaking the rules of the world that didn't happen
so i think in an attempt to set things back on
track before further destruction an age of dark
is the way to go regardless of what happens in
this age of dark at the very least things will
transition back to the way it was supposed to be
however that might not be the actual ending given
the future titles some have debated on proper
endings and given the status of dark souls 3
linking the flame i think is the real ending and
is definitely the most agreed upon as just about
every person in this game will speak about linking
the flame we only hear about the age of dark from
kaathe who we have to jump through several hoops to
just even meet i can almost guarantee someone has
gone throughout the entire game and didn't even
know that an age of dark was the real option
because of how hidden it is and while it's not my
preferred ending continuing the age of fire would
set in motion numerous events for us to discover
dark souls 1 was a fantastic experience from
start to finish and while the road was a little
bumpy sometimes along the way its story wrapped
up wonderfully it's a game that i recommend
you play at least once in your lifetime as
you will never get to experience something like
this ever again but we're just getting started
but now we've made it to the outro thank you all
for watching today and i hope you all enjoyed
if you did please be sure to like and subscribe if
you're new we still have quite a few souls games
to get through so get ready as we're going to be
going through dark souls 2 next and i must say i'm
honestly quite excited and i hope you all
are too to wrap things up as always thank
you to my returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone goodbye